I remember I was in Italy I saw a
ladybug and I was like this ladybug has
no idea it's
Italian how many things are we
carrying around and who are you when you
drop them and which of those things are
undroppable science will say reality is
agreed upon group hallucination but
they'll say it originates in the brain
that's like you and I are having a dream
and I hold up a a ring box and I go this
dream is coming from this box like why
would a part of the dream be a reliable
source of the dream what the do we
know about the mind you can't remove the
Observer it's influencing and part of
and drenched in The observed you are the
observed right the idea that there is a
self right that is observing is is a
further illusion and that that self
resides somewhere inside your head and
that's hard to disabuse yourself because
it's so entrenched in our deep rooted
attachment to what is real